preparations are underway for the big
new year's eve party on the strip a few
hundred thousand people expected to show
up for the big fireworks event just a
few hundred thousand people all right as
hector mejia reports governor steve
ciscolek has called in the nevada
national guard to help out
this will not be a new assignment for
the nevada national guard roughly 220
guardsmen and women will ring in the new
year here on the las vegas strip and in
downtown they'll be here mainly for
support beefing up the security presence
as las vegas prepares for the new year's
eve celebrations it's globally known for
we had a look inside a briefing who's
deployed overseas
the nevada national guard reviewing
safety protocols at the speedway armory
we are ambassadors for the state of
nevada for everybody here celebrating
troops will assist metro police and
emergency management as the clock nears
midnight they have the guard there is
absolutely vital governor steve sisilak
stopped by to greet the troops he says
crowds will likely be smaller than
pre-pandemic years still officials are
preparing for a couple hundred thousand
people las vegas is moving forward with
2022 celebrations when other cities are
scaling back due to coven it's a tough
thing to balance the economy and the
safety of people you know we're trying
to keep people safe as we can and the
best way to do that is get vaccinated
and get boosted
same time we need to keep our economy
moving and these hotel rooms filled so
people can work it's been a busy year
for the national guard now a common
sight during the pandemic major general
andre berry from the pandemic
to helping with ppe
to helping with wildfires for them in
terms of preparation this is something
they're doing on a regular basis it's
just more you're in a different
environment this is more being on the
front line making citizens okay watching
for any potential threats are out there
and resorts rolled here right behind me
will be one of the new launching pads
for the fireworks show and we've also
learned out of the 220 troops 40 of them
will be stationed at umc and sunrise
hospital reporting on the strip hector
mejia live local now